[Música]
buen día tutor buenos días a todos
gracias por invitarme y voy a intentar
hacer un ejercicio de locura que es que
una conferencia mía sólo dure entre 15 y
18 minutos que es casi imposible con lo
que voy a tener que correr mucho
activismo y marcas que pueden tener de
relación podemos la coop los cdr con
nike levi's
o patagonia pues eso es el reto que voy
a marcar en estos próximos minutos
vamos a introducirlo a través de la
situación que estamos viviendo vimos la
cuarta revolución industrial esta mañana
es en y roca seguro que ha explicado que
implica cada revolución industrial en el
mundo básicamente cambios en la forma en
la que vivimos en la forma en la que
trabajamos en la forma en la que nos
relacionamos pero está donde las
máquinas juegan un protagonismo parecido
a las que hasta ahora han jugado las
personas todavía va a ser seguramente
más significativa y va a generar cambios
más profundos a los que tenemos nosotros
actualmente
estos cambios ya lo estamos viviendo
desde el año 2000
y trazó una línea hacia atrás internet
buscadores
teléfonos móviles
smartphones
y commerce redes sociales
plataformas digitales
cambio más rápido que nunca nunca ha
habido en la historia de la humanidad
tantos cambios que afecten a la forma en
la que vive el ser humano en tan poco
periodo de tiempo
y uno de ellos es la información el
sobre volumen de información que genera
el planeta y el ser humano
y actualmente está generando cambios en
la forma en la que nos relacionamos
esa democratización del poder de los
medios que siempre habían estado en unos
pocos que difundían básicamente la
información de forma controlada
que la información
la pueda generar cualquier ser humano a
través de las redes sociales es
realmente un cambio muy muy
significativo buscaba datos esta semana
hoy ahora en un minuto hay 250.000 teams
abiertos videoconferencias
os imagináis cuántas había en febrero
del año pasado
yo creo que todo el mundo era reactivo
hacer una videoconferencia de trabajo
pero
en un minuto
what's up transacción a 41 millones de
mensajes
eso es la
relación entre seres humanos que hay en
tan solo un minuto en el mundo
el móvil el móvil ha cambiado la forma
en la que nos relacionamos pero también
la forma en la que conocimos la
información es la primera pantalla
en la que consume
plataformas de streaming
un
joven de menos de 20 años
pero es la plataforma que utiliza
de media un español 61 horas al día hay
al día la a la semana para hacer
multitud de cosas
es decir el móvil es el centro de
nuestra conexión con el resto del mundo
es un apéndice que se ha convertido en
parte de nosotros mismos y finalmente
las redes sociales las redes sociales y
un hashtag son capaces de invadir
seguramente el congreso de la democracia
más potente que hay en el mundo
un tuit de un presidente en contra de su
democracia utilizando una red social
una red social que sube 350 mil stories
por minuto
una red una red social
sube 500 horas de vídeo por segundo
todo esto nos ha llevado a una cosa que
podemos llamar activismo
que la población
gracias a todas estas herramientas y al
balance del poder de la comunicación y
la información
más una situación crítica del planeta ha
decidido tomar las calles cuándo y cómo
quiere de la forma que le apetece
y movimientos que hubieran costado en
tiempo de organización años se organizan
en semanas y son capaces de en horas
tomar las calles de países para hacer
cambios más profundos que haría
cualquier partido político y hemos visto
eeuu hemos visto chile estamos viendo
colombia estamos viendo continuamente
países países países
la manipulación del break sheet en la
unión europea por tanto es absolutamente
transversal a toda la humanidad
eso hace
que las empresas no puedan estar
a parte de ese movimiento social no
pueden aislarse
y eso va a generar un profundo cambio en
la forma en que las empresas se
relacionan con el mundo
y con los seres humanos que al final son
sus consumidores y ese activismo que lo
hemos visto por ejemplo en black las
madre a partir de un policía
y obviamente
provoca una temeridad que es matar a un
ser humano por su color de piel
seguramente ese trato no hubiera tenido
igual con un blanco genera un movimiento
que en fuerza en intensidad y en cambios
tiene más potencia que toda la vida
política de malcom x o seguramente ha
hecho más por la población negra de eeuu
que hizo obama en dos legislaturas
este movimiento no sólo llena calles y
bloquea la capital del país
sino que ese movimiento acaba
consiguiendo tener una plaza
con su nombre en tan solo unas semanas
y eso podríamos replicarlo a través de
ejemplos
múltiples de formas muy diferentes
aquí es donde empiezo a hacer la
reflexión de dónde venían las marcas
dónde empezaron las marcas y dónde
acabará esto
las marcas inicialmente utilizaban su
producto
como forma de expresarse el mundo es lo
que se llama marketing driver
coges tu producto defines un
posicionamiento y le explicas al mundo
lo que quiere ser y pongo cocacola
porque el mejor ejemplo es la felicidad
happiness el territorio que coca-cola ha
estado comunicando comunicando
comunicando durante
decenas de años desde que existe no se
ha movido el territorio happiness y si a
cualquier persona le dices que significa
la felicidad en un producto es cocacola
eso es caduco y cocacola abraza como
procedimiento la felicidad sin nada más
no va a ningún lugar
segundo gran salto que hacen las
compañías en el mundo del marketing
saltamos a lo que se llama purpose
driver y eso es decidir que tu misión
corporativa tiene un propósito y con ese
propósito quieres desarrollar producto y
quieres hacer cosas en el sector un
mercado en el que opere
mejor ejemplo yo creo que hay es apple
el zinc diferente le permite a apple
desarrollar un ordenador pero el día en
que decide saltar a un reproductor de
música
cambia absolutamente el mercado de la
música y cuando decide saltar a un móvil
y crea el smartphone cambia el mercado
de los smartphones el día en que apple
decida lanzar un coche sin duda
romperá en el mercado de los coches y
habrá por primera vez colas en un
concesionario de coches
un salto más allá de la responsabilidad
social corporativa
aquello que podemos llamar filantropía
corporativa
un gran ejemplo lo tenemos aquí no hace
falta saltar el charco soltar el
atlántico la fundació bancaria la caixa
a través de todo lo que tiene en
propiedades como encajaban como es
natural y como en repsol lo que ingresa
lo devuelve en filantropía
pero obviamente operan desde la banca es
muy difícil que te lo reconozcan
un siguiente salto es el caos marketing
que es decidir que tu producto
tiene un rol
determinado hacia el planeta y que sin
ese rol que tiene ese producto no vas a
desarrollarlo
por tanto abrazar una causa y tirar
hacia atrás para que el producto
represente esa causa
un brutal ejemplo es patagonia todo en
su desarrollo
ha planteado desde una causa de que el
producto sea lo más sostenible posible
con el planeta pero además de no vender
más de lo que toca y de intentar cuando
venden algo y recopilar recoger
productos que se dejan de usar para
ponerlos en una economía circular
un brutal ejemplo también de una campaña
que hicimos es y que en este caso es
marketing
bueno vamos a escribir la carta a los
reyes magos sevilla lo que vais a pedir
[Música]
muy
bueno
guitarra no me está
[Música]
estas las dejo aquí para mandárselas a
los reyes y ahora vais a escribir otra
carta una carta a vuestros papás el
primer año que trabajamos para ikea
que les pediría jce a vuestros papás
esta navidad llegó la navidad
hicimos una campaña anti consumista
y un experimento
porque esto no es una pieza de
comunicación para televisión
creemos son los niños que entraban con
los padres
a una tienda de ikea
padres que dejan a los niños en esa zona
para diversión y decidimos hacer un
experimento de escribir dos casos las
experimentos en casa que nos hagáis un
poco más de caso me gustaría que cenar
es más con nosotros quiero que me hagáis
cosquis así que les dejamos un cuento
quiero aquí estuvimos un día juntos
no puedo quiero jugar mamá que juegues
conmigo vaqueros quiere jugar más al
fútbol conmigo
os sorprende que os pidan esto para
navidad
[Música]
pues no la verdad es que no nos
sorprende a mí no tienen demasiado
juguete siempre
el sentimiento de tratar de sustituir
sustituir pues llenarles ese pequeño
vacío con un juguete que les
pasado todo el tiempo que tenemos al
máximo con nuestros hijos pensar que tú
quieres darles todo lo mejor y lo mejor
es que esto sí lo está escribiendo es
porque lo necesitan
así solo pudieras enviar una de las dos
cartas cuáles viarias la de los reyes
magos o la de papá y mamá
es una pregunta muy difícil
y
la de mamá
de mis padres
la fe y mamá
[Música]
la mejor forma de explicar
en navidad no quieres vender más sino
que lo importante es pasar más tiempo
con los tuyos
y damos el último salto que es el
activismo de marca esas empresas que
deciden tener una posición
ideológica sobre el planeta sobre la
política o sobre la sociedad
es
increíblemente arriesgado
obviamente porque es mucho más fácil no
significar té pero creo que es
decididamente el camino que tienen que
tomar las empresas si quieren significar
algo en la vida de las personas para
significar todo en la vida de las
personas hay que mojarse si quieres
conseguir un consumidor que realmente
decida diariamente consumir té a ti el
único camino es que te acerques
ideológicamente a lo que crea el
consumidor
y eso buena parte de razón tienen
personajes como este hay que agradecerle
al activismo a las marcas personajes
como trump que han generado que
compañías como levi's device para un
americano
decidida en plena campaña electoral
mojarse y decirle a la población
americana ve y vota un producto tan
antiguo como un tejano es tan antiguo
como el país
que puede ser lo más rancio que tenga
eeuu
y una compañía que se moja y decide ir
contra el presidente de ese país
y poner en su campaña a todas las
minorías que el presidente ha bobina
contra ellos
y esto es una maravilla de valentía una
compañía que después de tomar esta
decisión le suben las ventas
en el país y sube el valor de la acción
eso demuestra que será atrevido en ese
tipo de posiciones genera preferencia en
el consumo del consumidor y en segundo
lugar genera un emotional bond una
relación emocional con el consumidor que
no se puede conseguir de ninguna otra
forma
patagonia dios también ese salto
todavía más radical porque obviamente la
presión más pequeña y tiene muy claro
que va a un segmento mucho más fácil
pero el ejemplo brutal es nike un un
deportista
tiene que dejar de jugar
profesionalmente al fútbol americano
porque decide poner una rodilla en el
suelo cuando suene el himno de eeuu
y este deportista lo echa no puede
volver a jugar y su marca
que tiene un contrato con la nfl le
defiende a él y hace de eso una razón
para hacer campaña
y acaba diciendo si crees en algo tienes
que defenderlo hasta el final
y defendemos que no se puede pisar a las
minorías y que tiene que haber libertad
de opinión otra vez las las acciones de
la compañía suben y vende más
finalmente una campaña que para mí es
una maravilla
que obviamente es nuestra pero como la
de ikea pero no por eso la pongo sino
porque es una maravilla para explicar la
diferencia de género y de un briefing de
una compañía que su diferenciar ya que
era la primera compañía de inversión
100% gestionada por mujeres lo que
hicimos hacer es una estatua que se
plantará adelante el toro de wall street
que es el máximo significado del poder
económico en eeuu y pusimos a esta
chiquita allí en bronce después de
luchar contra el ayuntamiento nueva york
para que nos dejara instalarla una vez
la colocamos tenía que estar por un
periodo de un mes
esa estatua no la pudieron sacar hasta
el cabo de dos años porque la población
no le dejó sacarla porque las niñas de
eeuu que viajaban a nueva york su
primera foto que querían
esa foto
y porque cuando la hicieron quitar
tuvieron que encontrarle otra
localización en la ciudad para colocarla
porque les dio la gente
y una campaña de activismo de una marca
se convirtió en una
estatua que explica el movimiento
seguramente más importante que hay junto
al black light mother que hay en eeuu
y
como que ya he pasado de tiempo este
vídeo lo podéis encontrar en internet
explica todo el caso y veréis oa partir
solo de colocar la estatua los medios de
comunicación lo convierten en un sitio
mágico
[Música]
a partir de allí la población hace suya
la estatua
y una marca acaba
revirtiendo en muy positivo
un posicionamiento es gran activismo
desde el nombre del film es girl tiene
todo el significado del año
y eso además tenemos la ventaja para
hacerlo con todo lo que teníamos antes
tenemos data tenemos más datos que nunca
para saber las decisiones que tomamos y
que nos significan y segundo la
capacidad de una vez las tomamos
relacionarnos con la gente
las relaciones que la gente consciente
no las de las redes sociales que son
manipuladas y no consentidas son las
relaciones más fructíferas para crear
una marca que la gente ame y ese
activismo que decía las marcas es el
primer activismo que se puede convertir
en amor hacia las marcas y por tanto
defiendo que la única forma de construir
una marca es a través